اعلنا كل من مجلس السياده السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع موافقتهما المشروطه على
العوده الى مسار جده تفوضي الرامي لارساء
وقف مستدام لاطلاق النار واكد الطرفان
انهما يساندان اي حوار يقود الى حل سياسي
شامل في البلاد بالتزامن مع تجديد كل من
واشنطن والرياض التزامهما بانهاء الصراع
وتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه للسودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذكاء خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
الاعتبارات التي حكمت موقف الجيش والدعم
السريع في السودان من العوده الى مفاوضات
جده وهل فيها ما يستجيب لشروط الرعاه
المطالبه بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق نار مستدام
يفضي لتسويه
وكيف تبدو صله هذا المسار بغيره كذلك الذي
تقوده الايجاد في ضوء رفض رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني لكيفيه ادارته وما يرشح
عنه وفق ما شرحه البرهان في اتصاله
بالرئيس الكيني
وما الذي بوسع المجتمع الدولي فعله في هذه
المرحله من الازمه لاحداث اختراق نوعين
وملزم في جدارها وماذا اذا تعذر ذلك
مستقبلا
[موسيقى]
الى مدينه جده السعوديه تستعد الازمه
السودانيه لشد الرحال الى هناك عساها تعثر
على وقف مستدام لاطلاق النار عضو مجلس
السياده السوداني شمس الدين الكباشي قال
ان المجلس السيادي منفتح على اي مبادره
جاده لوقت الحرب في اطار المحافظه على
الدوله وسياده الوطنيه
الكباش اضاف ان المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه متقدمه وان موقف المجلس المبدئي
يدعم حوارا سياسيا شاملا قوه دعم السريع
اكدت على لسان يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لقائدها انها ملتزمه بمسار جده تفوضي
وانها مستعده للتفاوض مع الجيش
اضاف ان قوات الدعم السريع تنظر بايجابيه
لتصريحات الكباش
تتزامن هذه المواقف واعراب رئيس المجلس
السيادي السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
لرئيس كينيا عن رفضه لكيفيه طاعات الايجاد
مع الازمه السودانيه ولما يرشح عنها من
قرارات في المقابل اعلن قائد قوه الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو تشكيل لجنه اتصال
مع قوى سياسيه وحركات مسلحه للتواصل الى
حل سياسي شامل لازمه البلاد وبينما تراوح
تلك الازمه مكانها اكدت واشنطن والرياض
على التزام البلدين المشترك بانهاء الصراع
في السودان وتلبيه احتياجاته الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من الخرطوم عبر
الهاتف الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
الخبير العسكريه وقائد سلاح البحريه
السودانيه الاسبق ومن الخرطوم حافظ كبير
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كما ينضم الينا من
واشنطن سفير
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون افريقيا وابدا معك الفريق اول فتح
الرحمن محي الدين بالحديث عن
ما بدا وكانه تغير ولين في موقف الجيش من
التفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع حتى من اجل
الوصول الى تسويه سياسيه شامله بعد وقف
اطلاق النار هل نضجت الظروف من وجهه نظر
الجيش
التحيه ليك والتحيه للساده المشاهدين
وشكرا على الاستضافه حقيقه انا اعتقد انه
موقف القوات المسلحه اصلا لم يحدث في اي
تغيير وهات المسلحه منذ بدايه الحرب هي
امراه تحقيق السلام وايجاد حل فيلمي لهذه
الازمه من خلال التفاوض ولكن يعني يجب ان
يبقى التفاوض اولا بتحسين الوضع الانساني
لذلك كانت هنالك عده هدن
لتحسين الوضع الانساني ولكن للاسف كل هذه
الاذن اي شيء في الوضع الانساني بل زادت
الوضع الانساني تعقيدا
الازمه الحقيقيه في الوضع الانساني هي
ازمه احتلال منازل المواطنين المواطنين
مطرود من منزل من منزله بالقوه والمواطن
شربت سيارته المواطن قطعت عنه الكهرباء
والمياه وكيف يتحسن الوضع الانساني
الانسانيه ليست ازمه دواء وغذاء الازمه
الانسانيه هي ازمه اخراج المواطن من منزله
هذه القوات المسلحه الان حريصه على يكون
هنالك وقفا لاطلاق النار لكن بشرط ان تكون
منازل المواطنين خاليه من العناصر التمرد
ان يعود المواطن الى منزله ان تعود
الخدمات الى المنازل عوده الى جده السيد
فتح الرحمن العوده الى جده الان هي من اجل
التوصل او للبحث في التوصل لاطلاق لوقف
اطلاق نار مستدام
وايضا من اجل امكانيه البحث في مخرج سياسي
لهذه الازمه وهذا امر مختلف عن السابق
عندما كان الجيش يقول انه ذاهب الى جده من
اجل البحث فقط في هدنه وانه غير معني باي
امر اخر لا بوقت اطلاق نار مستدام ولا بحل
سياسي
ما رايك
يا عزيزي لا اسفل القوات المسلحه منذ
البدايه تقول ان الحل السياسي لن يكون الا
بعد ان تنتهي هذه الحرب بعد ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب
يكون هنالك اجماع شامل لكل القوه السياسيه
يتوافقوا على حكومه فتره الانتقاليه نصل
بها الى انتخابات هذا هو راي رواد المسلحه
منذ اليوم السادس عشر من ابريل لكن اثناء
الحرب لا مجالا لاي حديث عن حلب وهذا هو
نفس الموقف الان الان لا مجال للحديث عن
عن اي شان سياسي الان الحديث عن وقف
الاطلاق النار
ليحسن الوضع الانساني الوضع الانساني الذي
يتحسن والمواطن خارج منزلي من منزله
بالقوه القهريه للتمرد
من منازل المواطنين تخرج من المناطق
الخدميه تخرج من المستشفيات يعود
المواطنين الى منزله يكون هنالك وقفا
لاطلاق النارتم وبعد ذلك ندخل بمفاوضات
لايجاد حل لهذه الازمه
وهذا تماما ما اسال عنه سيد حافظ كبير
برايك ما هي الظروف التي دفعت ايضا قوات
الدعم السريع الى الذهاب نحو التفاوض
والبحث عن وقت لاطلاق النار وقت دائم
لاطلاق النار ومن ثم البحث عن تسويه
سياسيه وهو الامر الذي كان متعذرا في
الجولات السابقه من مفاوضات جدا
تحيه طيبه لكم ولي ضيوفك الكرام
والمشاهدين انا اعتقد ان
الوفد الدعم السريع لم يغادر جدا منذ
اليوم الاول لذهابه وظل مرابطا هناك بحثا
عن اتفاق
الوصول الى اتفاق بسبب مواقف الجيش وانه
انسحب وان تتعلم ذلك انسحب عن التفاوض
وكذلك يعني اصدر بيانا نشد فيه الوساطه
بالعوده عندما علقت المنبر لكن الظروف
التي جعلت الجميع يذهبون الى التفاوض من
جديد هي تعثر العمليات العسكريه وفشل
الجيش في العمليات التي اعلن عنها وسمها
بانها من اجل التنهاء التمرد وكذلك من اجل
فك الخناق على القياده العامه وعلى
القيادات
الكبرى التي تحاصرها يعني قوات الدعم
السريع في المدرعات وفي المهندسين وكذلك
في القياده العامه وكذلك الحديث الذي بدا
يتصاعد حول فراغ القياده بان السودان ليس
لديه قياده
تتحمل المسؤوليه وتتصدى لهذه المهمه
الكبيره وانها عاجزه عن التفاوض وعاجزه عن
الحرب وكذلك عجزه عن تمثيل المواطنين في
الدفاع عنهم وكذلك عن تمثيل يعني مصالح
السودان وبالتالي بدا هناك حديث في اوساط
مختلفه للبحث عن قيادات بديله نحن نتابع
ما يدور في اديس ابا قمه الايجار المصغره
للجنه الرباعيه وكذلك ضمن اخرى تتحدث عن
ان القياده الحاليه غير راقبه وغير غادره
وبالتالي غيرت موقفها
واتحدث انها يعني تريد التفاوض وتريد
تحقيق سلام لكن كثير من من المراقبين يشكك
في قدرتها على الالتزام يعني التفاوض اول
الالتزام حتى بيوقفي اطلاق النار باعتبار
ان هناك انقسامات كبيره جدا في الجيش هناك
تيارات ترفض تماما ابتداء التفاوض وتريد
فقط حزم الامر عسكريا الامر الذي تعذر حتى
الان لكن يعني حتى وان تحدثنا عن التفاعل
وهو الطريق المعلوم لاي نزاع عسكري هناك
اجنده سياسيه هناك
نحن نراقب ونعلم بان هناك يعني سنعود
للحديث عن التفاوض والتفاوض على ماذا
ولكن سيد ديفيدشان الولايات المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ترعيان هذه المفاوضات في جده كان لافتا
كلام شمس الدين كباشي بالامس ان ان
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه مبادره
متقدمه هذه المره هل الشروط الان التي
كانت تضعها الرياض واشنطن وهي الالتزام
والجديه من الطرفين في التفاوض هل توفرت
الان برايك
انا اعتقد ان شروط تحقيق هدنه طويله الامد
اكثر تقدما مما كانت عليه
في اخر مره بدلت في هذه الجهود في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه للتوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار اعتقد ان المسار لا يزال طويلا قبل
التوصل الى اتفاق بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع
لاتفاق على وقف لاطلاق النار يكون دائما
مستمرا مستداما وتحترمه الاطراف جميعها
اعتقد ان هناك توقعات متدنيه
في الاجتماعات المرتقبه في جده من المهم
ان تقام من المهم ان نحاول ولكن لا اعتقد
ان الكثير قد تغير حتى الان ولكن الا ترى
بكلام عضو مجلس السياده
الكباشي عندما اشار الى استعداد الجيش
للتفاوض ولايجاد حل سياسي الا ترى هذا
الموقف متقدما من الجيش
طبعا هناك اراده حقيقيه لاجراء محادثات
حول الوضع السياسي على المدى الطويل وهذا
مهم جدا
ان يحصل الى ان يتم تنفيذ وقفا لاطلاق
النار
وليس او بدون بدون وقف اطلاق النار ليس
هناك مشاركه للمدنيين في هذه المباحثات
يجب ان يكون جزءا لا يتجزا من هذه
المباحثات اذا الاراده لاجراء هذه
المحادثات جيده جدا ولكن سبقت جهود وحصلت
تصريحات من قبل بالنسبه لهذه المباحثات
السياسيه ولم تفضي الى شيء في الماضي عود
لك سيد فتح الرحمن محي الدين
الى اي مدى
ما ورد في مخرجات قمه الايجاد لا سيما ما
يتعلق بالتلويح
بنشر قوات شرق افريقيا في السودان الى اي
مدى كان هذا الامر عاملا ضاغطا على الجيش
من اجل الذهاب والقبول بمسار جدا من جديد
على اعتباره ربما يكون اقل ضررا من الدخول
في ازمه مع الايجاد على مستوى نشر قوات
افريقيه في السودان
بالعكس تماما انا اعتقد انه طبعا مخرجات
ايجاد كانت تاتي في اطار المؤامره
الاقليميه ضد السودان بالتنسيق الدعم
السريع المتمرد هذه المؤامره التي كان
يقودها الرئيس الكيني وانا اقول ذلك
ومسؤول عن هذا الحديث هذه مؤامره كانت
تتحدث عن هنالك فراق في القياده هنالك
كبير جدا بسياده في السودان تم في قمه
ايجاد ولذلك السودان رفضت هذه القيمه
الجمله طبعا عزيزي لا يمكن لقوات شرق
افريقيا تتدخل في اي دوله وفقا لقانونها
بدون موافقه الدوله المعنيه والسودان لا
يوافق على دخولها وبالتالي لا مجال لقيمه
هذه ضحيه تماما بالقيمه التي عقدت في
القاهره قمه دول جوار السودان التي حضروها
سبعه رؤساء الدول كل الدول جوار السودان
ابحثت تماما تلك القمه التي كانت فقط
للرئيس الاثيوبي والرئيس الكيمي وكل
مخرجاته تعتبر الان في ملقيه تماما ما
تحدث به ضيفك الكريم الاستاذ حافظ فيما
يتعلق بفراغ القياده هذا ياتي في اطار هذه
المؤامره الاقليميه التي كانت تسعى الى
السودان
وتزعزعني في سياده السودان الامر الاخر
الحديث عن ان الحزم العسكري فشل انا اقول
له الحكمه العسكري نجحت تماما وحقق
85% من مقاصده الان 85% من قوه التمرد قد
انتهت تماما قد
ره التكيرين انتهت
تماما نحن
مرحله امنيه خرجنا من العمل العسكري الى
العمل الامني لانه اصبح عناصر ارهابيه
مجرمه تروي عن مواطنين ارتكبت كثير من
الجرائم التي تعد جرائم ارهابيه المؤسختها
هي نفسها بيدها والان
وجدت اذانه من الامور المعلوم
سيكون التفاوض يعني اذا اذا كانت الامور
وصلت الى هذا الحد
لماذا التفاوض اذا نحن
انا اقول لك ثاني يعني قلت لك هذا الحديث
التفاوض لكي تخرج هذه العناصر المتمرده من
منازل المواطنين لكي تخرج من الاعيان
المدنيه لكي تخرج من المستشفيات حتى يتحسن
الوضع الانساني هذا هو الغرض من التفاوض
ثم بعد ذلك بعد ان تخرج هذه العناصر يتم
تصنيفها كل من ارتكب الجريمه يجب ان يحاكم
عليها كلا من اغتصب او سرقه او دمر يجب ان
يحاسب على جريمته هي التي لا ترتكب اي لم
ترتكب باي جرائم يمكن ان يتم استعاده
القوات النظاميه او تسريحها حسب الرؤيه
المسلحه هذا هو مجال التصاور لكن نحن نلضي
الى تصنيف هذه الجماعات في اعتبار جماعات
ارهابيه والعمل يمضي في هذا الخط
بخطى احاسيسه جدا هل سمعني دهانات من كثير
من الدول الكبرى في العالم
لماذا الجماعيه والسرقه
وانتهاء الانسان بشكل سار جدا وم ستمر
نفسه وليس من جهه اخرى
طيب اسمح لي اعوذ الا
من جديد نعم
العسكريه ما من قوه نجحت تماما في
الحل العسكري نجح تماما سيد حافظ كبير
يعني في المقابل
قوات الدعم السريع ليست في احسن حال هي
تحت المجهر هي متهمه من منظمات حقوقيه
باعمال بجرائم حرب جرائم ضد الانسانيه
اصابع الاتهام موجهه اليها بما حصل في غرب
دارفور فبالتالي ايضا الان هي مازومه
هذه القوات الى اي مدى هذا الامر ايضا
دفعها
للقبول بحل سياسي وتفاوض الان باي ثمن
وكما قلت لك هي لم ترفض ابتداء الحل
التفاوضي او الحل المتفاوض عليه لكن
بالفعل كل ما طالع امد الحرب هناك تعقيدات
كثيره جدا الانسانيه وكذلك تعقيدات يعني
فيما يخص حقوق الانسان هذا كله يحتاج الى
تحقيق الى ضبط يعني وبالتالي الطريقه
الامثل والطريقه الاقصر لوقف هذه
الانتهاكات هو وقف الحرب والتفاق على
ترتيبات سياسيه وامنيه يعني وقف الحرب
وكذلك للمضي قدما في اصلاح الاجهزه
الامنيه الاجهزه التي فشلت في حمايه
المدنيين وفشلت كذلك في ان
تقدم لهم يعني حتى في الخلاف فيما بينها
اداراتها المختلفه ما حدث هو دليل على فشل
المنظومه العسكريه
بالتمام وانها غير مؤهله بشكلها وضعها
الحالي لحفظ السودان وحفظ يعني الوطن
وكذلك حفظ الدستور وبالتالي كان هناك حوجه
هناك حديث حول الاصلاح الامني والعسكري هو
ما قاد الى هذه الحرب او ما كان يعني جزءا
كبيرا في هذه الحرب لا بد منه لا بد ان
يكون حاضرا في التفاوض اصلاح الاجهزه
الامنيه كلها سواء كان الشرطه او الامن او
حتى
وصول الى جيش عفوا يعني انت تتحدث في مكان
اخر هدفه العمليه السياسيه انت تتحدث في
مكان اخر مختلف كليا عما ذكره السيد فتح
الرحمن الفريق اول فتح الرحمن هو يقول ان
التفاوض على خروج الدعم السريع من المقرات
الحكوميه مما منازل ومساكن المواطنين
ومقرات الخدمات هذا هو التفاوض وهذا شرط
من من شروط التفاوض
ولم يكن لم يكن الخلاف ابتداءنا والحرب لم
تدور حول بيوت المواطنين او حول
الانتهاكات الحرب لديها اجنده ولديها
قضايا وبالتالي هذه القضايا هي قضايا
الحرب اما التي تحدث عنها هي افرازات
الحرب وبالتالي يعني لا يمكن لعقل ان يصدق
ان هناك مفاوضات تدور حول خروج القوات
المسلحه او القوات اي قوات مسلحه من مكان
الى مكان اخر دون التطرق الى الاجنده
والقضايا التي بسببها دخلت الاطراف في حرب
وبالتالي نحن عندما تحدث عن الانتهاكات
هناك تاريخ طويل يعني من الانتهاكات اغلب
القوات المتهمه وهذا يدل على انها تحتاج
الى اصلاح وتحتاج الى وضع يجعلها تحت
الاداره المدنيه
والاداره المدنيه هي التي تحدد اهداف
وتحدد هيكل وتحدد اعداد ورؤيه السودان
الامنيه كيف تكون حفظ النظام حفظ الدستور
حفظ التحول الديمقراطي هذه كلها
العسكريين الان يريدون الاستفسار بالسلطه
عفوا الطرفان سيكونان في جده لجوله
مفاوضات جديده سيد ديفيد
الا يفترض هنا بالولايات المتحده ولافت
انك لا تعلق امالا كبيره على هذه
المفاوضات او المشاورات المرتقبه لكن الا
يفت رض هنا بالولايات المتحده استثمار او
استغلال هذه الفرصه باي شكل من الاشكال
للضغط على الطرفين خصوصا مع مرور اربعه
اشهر من الحرب من دون
حسمها بشكل واضح من اي طرف
متفائلا كثيرا بشان نتائج هذه الجهود التي
ستبذل من اجل التوصل الى هدنه او وقفان
طويل الامد لاطلاق النار وفتح ممرات
انسانيه وتعامل مع الازمه السودانيه
الانسانيه من المهم بذل شهود من اجل
التقدم في
مفاوضات السلام لعل وعسى هذه المفاوضات
تنجح انا لست متفائلا لان الجهود الكثيره
بدرت من قبل وفشلت بمجرد ان طرفين تعهد
باحترام وقف اطلاق النار وفعل ذلك لفتره
قصيره قبل انهيار وقف اطلاق النار والعوده
الى الاقتتال اذا امامنا مسار طويل قبل
تحقيق النجاح الفعلي وانهاء الحرب ماذا
بامكان المجتمع الدولي هنا ان يفعل او ان
يضغط هل لديه هو سائل الضغط يعني الولايات
المتحده
ذهبت باتجاه العقوبات
كحاله ضغط لكنها يعني بدا وكانها لم تسفر
عن شيء هذه العقوبات
انتم محقون فهذه العقوبات لا يبدو انها
افضلت الى الكثير الولايات المتحده قد
فرضت عددا من العقوبات وذلك على الطرفين
ولكن لم تحقق انجازات كبيره
بقيت عقوبات قليله يمكن للولايات المتحده
ان تفرضها
ما تبقى هو
ان الدول التي تدعم او التي دعمت في
الماضي طرفا او اخر يجب ان تتوقف عن هذا
الدعم هذا من شانه ان يؤثر ربما
ولكن قليله هي الجهد التي يمكن الولايات
المتحده ان تبذلها للمزيد من الضغط بعكس
الدول الاخرى دول فيلم من تقاعدوها
الاقليميه ولا سيما دول في الخليج باختصار
سيد فتح الرحمن
ماذا لو لم تصل تلك المفاوضات المرتقبه
الى اي نتيجه باختصار
سيد فتح الرحمن
فقدنا الاتصال مع الفريق اول فتح الرحمن
محي الدين
اطرح السؤال عليك سيد حافظ كبير يعني هل
هناك امكانيه لان تكون تلك المفاوضات
المرتقبه كسابقتها وماذا اذا
فشلت ما البديل
يعني هناك حديث حول تغيير القياده اقصد
قياده الجيش اذا فشلت المفاوضات هذا يعني
واحد واحده من اثنين اما ان هذه القياده
غير قادره او غير راقبه في المضي قدما في
المفاوضات وتوقيع اتفاق وبالتالي هناك
حديث عن البحث عن اخره حكومه كانت تتمتع
بشرعيه وهي حكومه الدكتور عبد الله حمدوك
وكذلك التشاور مع طيف من القوه السياسيه
التي ايضا انقلب عليها في الخامس والعشرين
من اكتوبر من عام 2021 وبالتالي تكون
لديها يعني
صلاحيات او لديها يعني سلطات التشاور مع
المجتمع الدولي لاتخاذ ما يمكن اتخاذه
باتجاه السودان هناك ايضا عدد من
الحلول المطروحه ربما يعزل القائد العام
للجيش ويتولى قياده جديده شكرا جزيلا لك
حظ كبيره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
الخرطوم وشكرا للسفير ديفيد من واشنطن
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤ
افريقيا طبعا الشكر موصول لضيفنا من
الخرطوم الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
الخبير العسكري وقائد سلاح البحريه
السوداني الاسبق والذي كان معنا عبر
الهاتف انتهت حلقتنا مشاهدينا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]